und es geht auch seien die tief in den
eurofighter ist ein flieger der vierten
generation mit modernster elektronik an
bord sogenannten swing funktion als er
kann auch nicht nur potenzielle rolle
weg sondern auch noch in der luft dass
sie außergewöhnlich ist das kann dieser
eurofighter bedarf auch dementsprechend
der vorbereitung und planung mit einem
so genannten mission support system
wurde pilot schon im vorfeld seine
mission seine daten eingeben kann um den
flieger auf seine vorgaben vorzubereiten
der flieger weiß dann schon im vorfeld
wo fliegen wir heute in welchen luftraum
geht es wenig übung wird stattfinden und
das ist dort zu erwarten rolle
vielleicht ein paar technische daten
noch dazu für den eurofighter was macht
ihn so überlegen ja vor allem seine
leistungsfähigkeit des eurofighter wie
schon gesagt modernste generation delta
flügelprofil ein sehr schnelles profil
sehr wendiges flugzeuge wurde sehr
sensibel ausgelegt also mit einem
vierfachen fly by wire system als er
wird also mit bits und bytes
kontrolliert der pilot gibt grass ist
einen wunsch ein und der fliege regiert
dann darauf er rechnet im hintergrund
wie schwer sind wir wie schnell sind wir
wie hoch sind wer und da gibt er die
maximalen belastungen frei und die sind
in der regel bis zu 9g als der pilot
wird im cockpit neunmal so schwer mit
der anziehungskraft wie am boden wo wir
jetzt angehen und recht entspannt am
boden stehen aber das ist dann wirklich
schwer bei und harte arbeit für die
piloten im cockpit und wird schon sehen
bei dem man über den wird dann auch
darauf hinweisen wo dies einen hohen g
kräfte dann auf schienen wir dann schwer
dagegen arbeiten muss
erinnern sie hat seinerzeit sind die
jacken stationiert gewesen
wir haben damals ja
erlebt dass allein das land der vorgang
sehr kompliziert war dass man irgendwo
bei brokern der nur herunterzählen
musste diesen flieger die schnauze
aufgestellt und der ordnungspolitik land
eine schwierige sache damals
was hat sich da geändert ja das war
natürlich ein quantensprung wenn ich das
sagen darf das war quasi kochen mit
offenem feuer zur mikrowelle dieser
quantensprung den wir also alle kennen
so jetzt einmal von dem her es wird die
arbeit sehr leichter im cockpit durch
die modernste elektronik natürlich aber
auch durch die daten vielfalt die
fliege kommunizieren untereinander nicht
nur die flüge sondern auch mit der
luftraumüberwachung zentrale in sankt
johann im pongau wird kommuniziert und
typisiert auch dieser luft lage
austausch damit ist der pilot auch wenn
er nur passiv unterwegs ist oder ohne
aura der abstrahlung kandidaten
aufnehmen und sensorik dahingehend
abstimmen ok trucking werden wir auch so
kommt der letzte flugfähige tragen aber
dazu später
ja und jetzt beginnt so eben
einfach die damen und herren im
livestream begrüßen recht herzlich
willkommen hier in zeltweg wir sehen
gerade wir abhebt spiegel peter einsatz
pilot hier in zeltweg in der eurofighter
staffel ein sogenannter riedstadt dass
er
härter soll dem gasbrenner gezögert
und auch wir sehen dass er hier also was
senkrecht starten kann ungefähres
gewicht heute 16 tonnen die hier bewegt
werden die leistung ungefähr 100.000 ps
die usa 16 tonnen durch die luft bewegen
dementsprechend können auch diese
manöver ausgeführt werden und sie werden
sehen wie eng der radius ist bei den
manövern diese tätigkeit dieses flugzeug
wenn man das früher vergleicht mit einem
sarg tragen herkömmlicher erster zweiter
generation
das sind andere wege dann zu bewältigen
ja man hat immer gesagt der friede kann
in österreich gar nicht unter in tirol
ist sehr schmal als mit dem eurofighter
kann man drei vier mal auf diesem engen
tal unter entsorgen von daher aufgrund
dieser wendigkeit und messer sehr
schnell draußen aber kann die luft von
der oberösterreich erwarten dafür geht
bis zu über zweifacher
schallgeschwindigkeit
als einmal ist wirklich sehr schnell
auch an der westgrenze bezüglich der
ostgrenze oder an der nordgrenze oder
südgrenze stuft ran und kann es hier
sehr schnell reagieren im rahmen der
luftüberwachung
luftkampf manöver aus
wir werden natürlich manuell beim
loskauf braucht die werden nicht nur
hintergrund und fortgeschrittenen
schulung über kopf manöver durchgeführt
sondern dieser marker braucht man auch
tatsächlich beim luftkampf bestehen zu
können fertigt nicht nur kampf auf große
entfernen sondern auch auf entfernen so
genannte doppik bewegt und da braucht
man diese wenigkeit das flugzeug und
werden in kürze wieder dran vorbei
kommen in einem rückflug mit einem
manöver war dann negativ wegdrücken wird
es ist ja unangenehm ist man über für
den piloten weil dann weil es immer
bedacht im flugzeug positive belastungen
aufzubauen damit das blut vom kopf in
die pläne ab sagt aber nicht umgekehrt
weil dann der augendruck sehr hoch
steigt und so einem sogenannten redet
kommt und das würde so sehr angenehm
sein komplize richtung westen auf uns
wie dazu
winkt uns zu quasi ja grüßt uns aus der
luft jahr kann es auch sehr gut sehen
auch bei der boa ist auch für die
piloten dann ein einzigartiges ereignis
wenn hier also dann habe er beiden tagen
jeweils 150.000 in summe 300.000
zuschauer erwartet oder kommen werden
bei normaler weise unser geschäft hoch
über den wolken bis zur 15 60 kilometer
im luftraum über österreich stattfindet
und das unter ausschluss der
öffentlichkeit quasi und darum ist
sondern für den pilot noch etwas
besonderes eine demonstration also hier
direkt vorführen zu können
wir sehen sehr schnell die hohe rate
hier zb
max performance türen also hier bei der
fonds bis zu 79 g in den sitz gedrückt
immer noch 90 grad führt eine rolle
durch also sehr wenig das flugzeug
mindestflughöhe sind 100 meter über
grund internationale regularien die
eingehalten werden auch der abstand zu
den zuseher und themen sprechen wird
natürlich auch bei der erba eingehalten
und hier allen sicherheitsregularien zu
entsprechen
nachdem er hier seemanöver mengen radios
zugeführt hat wir jetzt einen aufschwung
durchführen richtung nordwesten dann
wegdrehen und dann aus richtung
nordwesten ihnen im rücken flog wo er
bis zu minus 3 g auftreten wie schon
gesagt dass kopf das blut schießt ihn
dann in den gruppen muss dagegen
ankämpfen der pilot trägt und positive g
belastungen
aushalten zu können um in diese neuen g
aushalten zu können einen speziellen
anzug einen sogenannten anti g anzug der
also auch über den bauch in der end
bereich bis zur wade mit der luft
gefüllt ist dann bei hoher belastung und
hier das abfließen des blutes in die
unteren extremitäten verhindern soll
wie gesagt es ist schwer arbeit für den
piloten im flugzeug sehr mitleidenschaft
gezogen natürlich auch der ganze apparat
das rückgrat der nackten bereich die
wirbelsäule die bandscheiben werden ist
er hier sehr gefordert hier dieses mal
angesprochen manöver ist sie da auf uns
herab wir können ihm zuwinken jasid uns
drückt kurz weg geht in der normale
rücken fluglage etwas angenehmer wie in
einer in einer kurve drückt noch einmal
hoch auf bis zu minus drei gerold dann
wieder auf und jetzt kommt die kurze
phase wieder der entspannung bis er sich
für das nächste manöver vorbereitet wie
gesagt alles man darüber die hose in der
grund fortgeschrittenen und auch bei
luftkämpfen manöver natürlich
durchgeführt werden wir befinden uns
hier genau auf den 5 die fliege afrika
truppen schule beheimatet ist mit dem
institut flieger wo es diese
grundausbildung stattfindet wir haben
sie eben auch die letzte selektion für
heuer also abgeschlossen die user dann
mit der b 7 in ihrer schulung beginnen
in weiterer phase dann geht es nach
lecce italien für die phase 3 und für
die phase der ausbildung bzw
auf dem hubschrauber wo wir auch gerade
dabei sind wir haben den ersten kurs
bereits seit juli laufen
in italien
auf die a b 169 was für uns ein großer
gewinn ist ja moderne technologie
modernes gerät was für ein breites
spektrum eingesetzt werden kann und da
sind wir sehr froh dass dieses gerät
auch beschafft wurde und den zulauf in
österreich finden wird
nachdem ceo fred den wir treiben gesehen
haben mit fahrwerk draußen oder wieder
den nachbrenner gezündet steigt wieder
hoch und in kürze zeigt auch dass er
nicht nur langsam fliegen kann also
langsam heißt ungefähr 110 knoten das
sind rund 200 km h es ist für einen
flieger dieser generation auch
außergewöhnlich weil ältere profile sei
es abtragen mit 21 diese generationen
die könnten in diesem
geschwindigkeitsbereich nicht mehr
fliegen auf grund der motten elektronik
kann dass der eurofighter und jetzt
zeigt er uns aus richtung südwesten
wieder kommend einen schnellen überflug
und hier begrenzt bei der airpower
mitmachen 09 also im unterschied bereich
maximal 900 km h aus sicherheitsgründen
normalerweise die zweieinhalbfache
schallgeschwindigkeit ist über 2.500 km
h wären möglich wir sehen hier rückt der
schall computer her
wir brauchen diese überschall fähigkeit
um auch entfernte luftfahrzeuge sehr
rasch aus einem alarm stadt abfangen zu
können das heißt wir sind hier
365 tage im jahr auf einsatzbereitschaft
mit dem eurofighter der jederzeit
alarmiert werden kann im verbund mit der
passiven luftüberwachung mit dem system
gold habe mit den ladestationen die
häuser hier das luft lage beliefern und
im anlassfall einen alarm stadt
generieren und dirk angesteuert werden
wer kann gesteuert werden aus einer
auch seinerseits bereitschaft wo wir
quasi im flieger schon sitzen das
flugzeug vorbereitet ist und in wenig
minuten ca 3 minuten in die luft kommen
bis hin der unerwartete alarm statt wo
die piloten vorbereitet sind im verbund
mit der technik das flugzeug
durchgecheckt haben dann dauert es
maximal neun minuten also ohne
vorwarnung de facto und distanziert
zweimal sehr hohe geschwindigkeiten
erreichen kann um eben diese west ost
nord oder süd grenzen zu erreichen
schaut euch schon relativ schnell aus
man musste dann kann man davon ausgehen
dass auch bei diesem schnellen flug wenn
er die volle leistung bringt noch einmal
zwar heute so schnelles wir jetzt ja da
ist er dann wirklich sehr gesteht in der
luft ich vergleiche das immer für den
piloten ist es nicht sehr spektakulär
die 2
geschwindigkeit weil wir das meist in 10
15 km h erreichen
weil hier keine referenzen sind ist der
unterschied ob ich jetzt im ortsgebiet
50 km/h fahren oder auf der autobahn 130
auf der a 31 sind auch die spektakulär
im ortsgebiet wären sie doch sehr
interessant weil wir andere eindrücke
haben wir sind früher auf die flug
geflogen bis 40 meter über grund japan
hubschrauber geht es noch viel tiefer
und da sind die geschwindigkeiten dann
sehr beeindruckend
ja das sind jetzt die letzten manöver
unserer väter der hier eindrucksvoll
demonstriert hat diese
leistungsfähigkeit für österreich um
hier die souveränität die neutralität
österreichs hier zu schützen leider wir
brauchen gar nicht weit von österreich
wechseln ein trauriger anlass ja aber
wir sind da wenn etwas passiert um hier
dementsprechend eingreifen zu können und
brauchen auch dem entsprechendes gerät
und betroffen wird dass sich auch
dementsprechend unterstützt werden
dankeschön meine damen und herren ich
hoffe wir haben einen eindruck
vermitteln können dynamischen eindruck
dass das ein flugzeug und kein spielzeug
ist und ich bitte sie jetzt die plätze
einzunehmen
wir fahren fort mit der pressekonferenz
wir warten kurz bis die kameras auf
position sind
meine damen und herren er bauer 20 22 es
rückt näher auf unserer homepage sehen
sie wie herunter gezählt wird dafür die
journalisten auch sagen es ist demnächst
ab montag die möglichkeit dass sie sich
akkreditieren ich darf hier zur
präsentation des programms bei airpower
begrüßen unsere frau bundesministerin
claudia tanna die frau landesrätin
barbara ettinger mädel den chef der
flying bulls siegfried schwarz den
legendären chef den herrn breker tier
wolfgang prill er ist der gesamtleiter
für die ausrichtung der airpower im
bundesheer und den oberstleutnant thomas
ploder er ist verantwortlich für das
programm und die steuerung des gesamten
programms eigentlich vor allem wo sie
dann stattfindet wir werden von allen
herrschaften ihre statements hören ich
darf sie sehr geehrte frau
bundesministerin bieten mit ihrem
statement zu beginnen
vielen dank sehr geehrte frau
landesrätin herr schwarz herr brigadier
herr oberstleutnant sehr geehrte damen
und herren der medien
gab es ist ziemlich genau zwei monate
her als wir gemeinsam mit unseren
partnern mit dem land steiermark und mit
red bull die durchführung der airpower
in zweiter und dritter september im
fliegerhorst hinterstoisser in zeltweg
angekündigt haben und ich glaube nach
der dynamischen vorführung unseres
eurofighters steht es außer frage
warum wir diese durchführen sehr oft
wird er das bundesheer
angesprochen mit den dingen die wir
nicht können viel zu wenig oft mit denen
die wir können sie haben das jetzt
dynamische erlebt aber ich kann nicht
beginnen gerade nicht an dieser stelle
ohne danke zu sagen an all diejenigen
soldaten die zuluft und auch zu lande
insbesondere unsere pioniere gerade
jetzt in diesen stunden
unterstützend tätig sind nach der
katastrophe in kärnten und auch von
dieser stelle aus ein ganz großes
dankeschön sie wissen es sind über 170
pioniere im einsatz wie der bevölkerung
helfen die unterstützen und auch drei
unserer hubschrauber
die etwa 22 er wird eine unglaubliche
leistungsschau werden eine militärische
leistungsschau werden am boden es werden
vorführungen unserer österreichischen
luftstreitkräfte aber auch
internationaler militärischer
kunstflugstaffeln und teilnehmern aus
den verschiedensten bereichen auch aus
dem bereich der zivilluftfahrt natürlich
auch den freien bulls aber auch einer
seiner schau am boden einer statischen
von zivilen ausstellern aus den
bereichen der luftfahrtindustrie der
forschung und der lehre und auch eine
umfangreiche
rahmenveranstaltung am flugplatz gelände
inklusive der militärluftfahrt museum
bestehen wichtig ist auch anzusprechen
dass auch dieses mal der eintritt zur
airpower 22 frei sein wird wenn wir
wollen und ich hab das vor zwei monaten
auch angesprochen gemeinsam dass es auch
eine event für die ganze familie wird
dass es abwechslungsreiche unterhaltung
auch gibt gerade für kinder und ich darf
in diesem zusammenhang auch hinweisen
auf ein gewinnspiel auch ein besonderes
gewinnspiel dass sie auf der homepage
der airport 22 sehen können bei der
aktuell ganz sensationelle preise für
alle freunde unserer airpower verlost
werden das sind packages dabei mit
flügen mit der tc 6 eine nächtigung im
steyrer schlüssel und vip karten für
beide veranstaltungstage also schauen
sie sich das an für das österreichische
bundesheer für uns als veranstalter
veranstalter ist das eine ganz
erfreulich dass wir ein programm bieten
können auch dass eine glaube ich noch
nie dagewesene fühle zeigt mit
unglaublich vielen highlights und
premieren wir können das aber nur mit
unseren partnern tun daher an dieser
stelle vor landesrätin ein ganz großes
dankeschön noch an das land steiermark
und ein ganz großes dankeschön auch an
red bull die highlights die sie sehen
werden sehr geehrte damen und herren das
sind 35 flying displays mit acht stunden
programm im static display werden rund
60 luftfahrzeuge präsentiert eine zahl
die wir bei den vergangenen airpower
veranstaltungen so noch nie hatten eine
echte aber auch künstlerische retour
aufführen ist ein großes flying display
des österreichischen bundesheeres mit
insgesamt neun hubschrauber des typs
ice-3 einem eurofighter 3 bc 6 und einem
hubschrauber wurde vorhin schon
angesprochen wo wir ja neu beschafft
haben in der beschaffung sind
169 alle fluggeräte dieses displays
bewegen sich dann gemeinsam zu einer
eigens komponierten symphonie komponiert
und arrangiert von bekannten arrangeur
tristan schulze dazu werden sie aber
näheres dann von herrn oberstleutnant
thomas bruder noch hören und die
airpower 22 bringt er auch eines in
dieser region sehr geehrte damen und
herren nämlich eine enorme wertschöpfung
aber ich bin überzeugt davon dass dazu
die frau landesrätin eppinger
mittelmeeres ausführen wird bevor wir
dann zur vorstellung geben der
programmhighlights am 20
danke frau bundesministerin für das land
steiermark unseren langjährigen partner
begrüße ich die frau landesrätin barbara
ermitteln und bitte um ihr statement
geschätzte frau bundesministerin
geschätzte her an einem podium meine
sehr geehrten damen und herren sie sehen
auch mich nach dieser vorführung
wirklich fasziniert und beeindruckt und
diese faszination fliegen werden wir
auch in zweiter und dritter september
diesen jahres hier erleben und es stehen
die leistungen der pilotinnen und
piloten im vordergrund denen wir
wirklich allergrößten respekt und
wertschätzung
entgegenbringen aus wirtschaftlicher und
touristischer sicht frau
bundesministerin du hast das
angesprochen ist es für die ganze region
aber für die steiermark insgesamt ein
enormer gewinn wir werden bei den bis zu
300.000 besucherinnen und besuchern mit
zusätzlichen nächtigungen für unsere
region rechnen können bei der letzten
air power war es im bereich jura mutter
und ein plus von 37 prozent an
nächtigungen und das wirkt sich
natürlich positiv auch in die anderen
bezirke und regionen der steiermark aus
sehr hervorstreichen möchte ich auch
dass bei der veranstaltung
regionale unternehmen zum zug kommen so
werden beispielsweise rund 50
gastronomie betriebe aus der region die
möglichkeit hier haben unsere gäste zu
versorgen und das alles wird insgesamt
eine wertschöpfung von neun millionen
euro für die region bringen das immer
sehr sehr dankbar dafür darüber hinaus
haben wir einmal mehr die chance die
steiermark als urlaubsland aber auch als
innovationsstandort zu präsentieren denn
wir können mit 300 journalistinnen und
journalisten über die landesgrenzen
hinaus rechnen und so können wir auch
erwarten dass die bilder der airpower
und damit die bilder der steiermark und
dieser region in die ganze welt
hinausgetragen werden wir unterstützen
in erster linie seitens des landes das
rahmenprogramm und wir möchten im rahmen
dieses programm ist auch unterstreichen
dass die steiermark mittlerweile eine
große kompetenz im bereich luftfahrt und
raumfahrt aufgebaut hat die steiermark
ist als automobilland bekannt gerade
auch in dieser region durch den red bull
ring was aber viele nicht wissen ist
dass wir in unserem absatz tyria
mobilitäts casper mittlerweile auch 80
unternehmen haben die sich dem thema
luft und raumfahrt wittmann 3.000
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter sind
sie in der steiermark beschäftigt und
ein großteil aller flugzeuge weltweit
haben steirischer technologie mit an
bord seit es im bereich der federn sei
dass im bereich des interviews sei es im
bereich der triebwerke überall finden
sie steirische technologie und auch das
wollen wir im rahmen der airpower einmal
wir unterstreichen
forschungseinrichtungen und auch unsere
fachhochschule joanneum beispielsweise
werden hier ebenfalls als aussteller
dienern weil wir auch die chance nutzen
wollen um für entsprechenden nachwuchs
für diesen bereich zu sorgen insgesamt
für uns also ein ganz großer gewinn und
ich möchte mich den dank anschließend
allen voran bei der frau ministerin und
dem bundesheer als veranstalter und
unseren bewährten partner red bull die
mit ihren teams in den letzten monaten
hier großartige arbeit geleistet haben
und ich wünsche auch für die letzten
zwei monate der vorbereitung die noch
bleiben alles alles gute und wir sind
davon überzeugt dass es wieder eine
erfolgreiche veranstaltung werden wird
herzlichen dank baracke verwaltungsrätin
um jetzt zu konkretisieren wie das
programm ausschauen wird bitte ich nur
unter herrn august leiten und thomas
ploder denn
director flight track tor und display
director um sein wort
sehr geehrte frau bundesminister sehr
geehrte vor landesjagdgesetz der
brigadier liebe sie sehr geehrte
medienvertreter
gemeinsam mit dem siegel schwarz von den
flying bulls darf ich als dies bei
direkter heute die teilnehmer und die
programmhighlights der erbauer 22
präsentieren ich bin zum dritten mal im
engeren organisationsteam einer erbauer
veranstaltung und ich habe bei der
airpower 19 einmal eine frage zum
flugprogramm mit dem ausdruck
luxusproblem verwendet und wir haben bei
der airpower 22 ein noch nie dagewesenes
luxusproblem bezüglich teilnehmer
anfragen und flugprogramm
ich und mein display team haben das
flugprogramm auf acht stunden zu planen
und aufgrund der anfragen die wir
hereinbekommen haben könnten wir
wahrscheinlich eine flugshow mit 14
stunden befüllen bei den luftfahrzeugen
für die statische sieht es auch nicht
viel anders aus der brauch man schlicht
und einfach einen größeren flugplatz
dass wir alle flieger unterbringen
könnten die eigentlich gerne zu uns
kommen würden
sehr viele teilnehmer anfragen mussten
wir ablehnen und aufgrund der fülle von
highlights unserer air show war auch die
auswahl bezüglich der heutigen
präsentation nicht einfach für mich
ich hoffe dass jetzt niemand enttäuscht
ist den ich nicht erwähnen wäre
ich möchte mit den beiträgen des
österreichischen bundesheers beginnen
und zwar werden wir wie gerade eben
unseren eurofighter in einem solo
display sind
des weiteren wird eine abfang
demonstration mit zwei eurofightern und
einer c 130 hercules mit anschließend
der leistungs demonstration durch die
beiden eurofighter zu bestaunen sein
hier nur das stichwort top gun jeder war
hat sich vielleicht den film in letzter
zeit angeschaut also ein bisschen dieses
top gun feeling wird dann aufkommen wenn
sich die zwei eurofighter in bodennähe
in
simulierten luftkampf manöver und
gegenseitig bekämpfen also da kann man
dann das was man so kurzen in den
bildern im kino gesehen hat live bei der
airpower noch einmal beobachten
bei der airpower 22 gibt es unter
anderem den schwerpunkt ausbildung in
den luftstreitkräften und als beitrag zu
diesem thema werden uns die fluglehrer
des instituts fliegers mit drei dreiern
und der 40 und 4 beratungs pc-7 trennen
cobo trennen wir können im verband flug
vorführen
die künstlerische welt aufführung hat
die frau minister schon erwähnt mit den
neuen alle die mit der bundesländer
fahnen und begrüßen werden und
anschließend wird ein eurofighter und 36
noch den beitrag leisten mit zum schluss
einem highlight zu viel möchte ich nicht
verraten anschauen bei der japan
zu den internationalen teilnehmern an
der erbauer 22 freute es mich die
internationale die internationalen
kunstflugstaffeln und publikumsmagnete
aus italien die frecce tricolore zu
präsentieren die war die swiss wird wir
ihren künstlerischen beitrag leisten und
aus spanien die pathologie und aus
kroatien werden wir mit 6 bc 9 also mit
turboprop maschinen die griller julia
am himmel in zeltweg mit ihren
spektakulären manövern begrüßen können
beeindruckendes solo displays neben den
schon erwähnten eurofighter solo display
werden wir auch von mehreren f-16 und
krippen flugzeugen beobachten können
ein chat und propeller
trainingsflugzeugen werden leonardo dede
346 aus italien l 39 in tschechien
pilatus pc 9 aus slowenien und die als
von österreichische piloten geflogen pc
7 zu sehen sein ein leckerbissen aus dem
hubschrauber sektor wird das publikum
jedenfalls bestaunen können unter
anderem erstmalig bei einer
veranstaltung wird ein airbus helikopter
tiger in pflegen display vorführen
zudem werden auch viele historische
luftfahrzeuge im static und freien
display präsentiert alle epochen der
luftfahrt werden vertreten sein
angefangen von einer fokker 1 baujahr
1914 1914 bis 18 at 11 baujahr 1937
pilatus b2b 19 45 sowie eine antonov 12
1952 und wider der oberst schweiger
schon erwähnt hat den sub tracken darf
natürlich auch nicht fehlen
das bringt mich zum schluss wenn meines
kleinen auszug so ein teilnehmer an der
erbacher 22 vieles mehr wird natürlich
noch zusätzlich zu bestaunen sein und
ich möchte mich an dieser stelle auch
bei mir ein display team für die
bisherige zusammenarbeit bedanken und
ich freue mich auf eine großartige
ehrbarer 22
danke russland
aspekten herren begrüßen wir den
legendären chef der flying bulls den
herrn siegfried schwarz bitte um ihre
worte grüß gott mein name ist siegfried
schwarz ich bin der flugbetrieb den
chefpiloten flying bulls für
hubschrauber
und wie man chefin war sagt ich aber
auch die gnade der geburt den steiger zu
sein und die wohnung in der nähe von
hier und so ist es natürlich irgendwie
meine heimat der show also ich fliege
auf der ganzen welt der shows und hier
erzählt der bauer sind wir etwas ganz
besonderes deshalb nicht nur ich sondern
sogar alle anderen piloten die alle
gerne nachgekommen
der dank geht natürlich allen denen die
das möglich machen den sogenannten
winken und helfern die das ermöglichen
dass die erbauer stattfindet was sind
wir sehr dankbar dass das so
funktioniert
wir die flying bulls wir sind eine ganz
besondere gruppe unserer leidenschaft
ist die fliegerei ich glaube viele von
uns würden auch ohne gehalt arbeiten
und ich selbst war 20 jahre im
rettungsdienst und jetzt bin ich seit 20
jahren schon bei den flying bulls und
fliege in erster linie air shows und
natürlich auch den ganzen die ganzen
anderen flüge die für unsere firma
notwendig sind und wir wissen natürlich
dass das ein privileg ist bei uns
fliegen zu dürfen wir haben also vom
modernen düsenjäger bis zum doppeldecker
eine irrsinnige bandbreite an flugzeugen
und die wirklich selten sehen dort
einmalig auf der ganzen welt
die geschichte der flying bulls begann
ungefähr den 1980 er jahren und begann
mit einem einzigen flugzeug inzwischen
haben wir schon 40 produkts eugen der
hartplatz wird schon zu klein und wir
haben flugzeuge von der großen vier
motoren tc 6 bis zu einem 70 jahre alten
hubschrauber mit holz oder blättern und
alle diese flugzeuge sind flugfähig
unsere heimat ist also in salzburg der
hunger 7 und 8 jedes herzlich willkommen
uns zu besuchen
und dort werden die ganzen
fluchtfahrzeuge von unseren techniker
das sind ca 35 mann oder damen
die instand gehalten werden in einem
normalen jahr absolvieren und zwei
piloten in etwa 40 bis 50 vorführungen
hauptsächlich in europa einige sind also
weltweit
die ganzen displays werden also
monatelang einstudiert und trainiert
haben saisonbeginn wird immer eine woche
lang trainiert und dann wird dieses
ganze display wird dann ein ganzes jahr
lang geflogen
wichtigste punkt ist natürlich die
sicherheit und jeder handgriff muss also
wirklich sitzen
und bei den flying bulls ist also
besonders wichtig dass man ein
teamplayer ist wie fliegen nicht nur
solo displays und dann auch
informationen und vor allem
informationen wie sie sonst ganz selten
gibt das heißt düsenjäger
weltkriegs zur flieger
hubschrauber
fallschirmspringer also durcheinander
alles was die luft zu bieten hat bei der
airpower werden bei ungefähr mit 72 oder
ziemlich genau mit 72 mitarbeitern vor
ort sein und 29 luftfahrzeuge erbringen
ein teil dieser luftfahrzeuge fliegt ein
teil ist im static display
und wir nehmen das natürlich gerne die
zeit jeden den terra interessiert daran
ist die flieger zu zeigen zu erklären
und besonders freuen wir uns wenn das
natürlich junge leute sind die interesse
an der fliegerei hat und in der luft war
eines darf ich dann noch eines sagen wir
haben etwas ganz spezielles das ist der
so genannte robotik triple das
bereitet mir schon seit zwei jahren vor
und wir trainieren das auch laufend und
das ist ein zusammenspiel zwischen alten
flugzeugen kunstflugmaschine
fallschirmspringern links und fliegern
hubschraubern und das werden wir bei der
airpower das erste mal vorführen
vielmehr
ist mir gesagt von zurück darüber nicht
sagen und damit bin ich am ende danke
schön das ist schon spannend genug
und baut spannung auf wir werden von den
flying bulls im anschluss noch etwas
daneben zunächst habe ich aber über
leighton auf den herren privateer
wolfgang prill den chef der airpower
denn meine sehr geehrten damen und
herren als projektleiter darf ich ihnen
mitteilen dass die planungen für die
airpower 22 abgeschlossen sind die
konkrete vorbereitung wir dann 888
august hier in zeltweg beginnen wir
werden beginnen mit dem aufbau ab 22
august wird das personal
einflüssen und wird dann bis zum
programmbeginn am zweiten september auf
6.500 mitarbeiter anwachsen
mir ist eines ganz besonders wichtig
dass ich auch das verkehrskonzept
hinweise das ist bitte schon abrufbar
unter www airpower 22 punkte kommen sie
mit dem zug wir haben buslinien züge
angemietet zusätzliche von wien von
links von salzburg und von vielleicht
kommen sie direkt zum bahnhof hier in
zeltweg und hier können sie dann zu fuß
aufs veranstaltungsgelände kommen das
zweite ist wir haben buslinien 70
buslinien in ganz österreich
geplant mit 339 zug stieg stellen auch
das kann auf der homepage www rk 22
punkte at eingesehen werden und das
beste wäre nett wäre natürlich kommen
sie mit dem rad auch hier haben wir eine
menge von raad abstellplätzen hier
vorbereitet dann ein zweiter september
das ist natürlich das günstigste es gibt
auch eine begrenzte anzahl von
parkplätzen für kfz die sind ebenfalls
auf der homepage einzusehen und da kann
man sich darin bewegen der zweite punkt
auf war sich hinweisen möchte das ist
das gewinnspiel ist die frau
bundesminister bereits angekündigt hat
so etwas hat es noch nicht gegeben ein
flug mit einer der tc 6 der flying bulls
von salzburg nach zeltweg drei tage
unterbringung im steyrer schlüssel die
verpflegung hier vor ort in zeltweg bei
der erdbau in der rp und dann rückflug
mit der tc 6 von zeltweg nach salzburg
zweiter und dritter preis meine damen
und herren mit flüge für zwei personen
mit den flying bulls das alles kann man
sich nicht kaufen
es gibt noch weitere preise vierter bis
50 der preis sehen sie sich das an
erbacher 22 punkte ich bedanke mich auch
von meiner stelle bei den partner land
steiermark für die unterstützung bei den
preisen und auch bei red bull für die
unterstützung bei diesen preisen
ansonsten möchte ich hier endlich
bedanke mich für das interesse meine
damen und herren und wünsche uns allen
eine wunderbare ehepaar 22 taktischen
danke hat er mittlerweile sind die
flying bulls in startposition die
motoren sind eingeworfen bitte ein haus
zu mir
er wird die
[Musik]
nun folgende programm moderieren ich
danke ihnen für ihre aufmerksamkeit
möglichkeit für interviews mit den damen
und herren wird es im anschluss noch
geben
ja mein name ist also nicht mehr von
einem flying bulls ich glaube im krieg
war meine stimme die so bislang bedient
aber trotzdem wäre das beste daraus
machen auch im namen der flying bulls
nur ein herzliches grüß gott der bibel
nach vorn raus unsere maschine habe beim
anlassen es wird zwei drei minuten dann
dauern und auch wenn sie herauskommen
wollen ganz viel besser sehen es wird
zwar 23 minuten noch dauern der ablauf
der pressekonferenz dort bislang
schneller war als was vorher von uns
erwartet wissen ist und trompeter bisher
um geduld weil wir die maschine noch
umgehen
da habe ich mal hast du mit mir ganz
mit dem herstellen oder meint
wir haben die chance uns gemeinsam sie
haben eine erste jahr 2009 und da heute
erst das erste mal verantwortlich im
bereich der flying bulls für den ablauf
des fliegerischen ablauf von unserer
firma aus das war für mich sehr sehr
große herausforderung zu diesem
zeitpunkt und 2009 weg sagt weiter und
bei jeder erbauer in dieser
verantwortlichen position hat werde ich
meine letzte sein
und überall jedesmal immer wieder
begeistert davon was wir doch entweder
auf die füße stellen und auch hier wird
es wieder eine ganz interessante
geschichte werden wir haben gerade
gehört dass ihr 50 veranstaltungen haben
im jahr
im vergleich dazu
ist die airpower ein höhepunkt oder der
höhepunkt
wir haben jetzt
funkverkehr mit dem tower das heißt wir
müssen ein bisschen aufpassen was sie
sagen und dann können wir gleich wieder
bei ihnen
ok bei 50 veranstaltungen werden wo ist
dort die erbauer und zur sicherung also
die ehepaar ist für uns ein ganz am
obersten top-level anzusiedeln und wir
sagen wie gesagt sehr sehr viel bei den
verschiedenen veranstaltungen unterwegs
in europa es geht von norwegen bis
portugal von england bis in den osten
hinein und immer das immer wieder sauber
wir sehen natürlich sehr sehr viele
dinge dabei aber die erba ist eines der
beeindruckendsten größten
veranstaltungen dieser form gibt keine
veranstaltung erlebt die so ein großes
flugprogramm hat wo so viele flugzeuge
beteiligt sind wohl es beginnt um 9 uhr
vormittag und normalerweise darum 17 18
uhr endet also das ist sehr sehr
beeindruckend
ok
gärtner zwischendurch display gestartet
landschaftlich gibt es einige sehr mir
sollen fotografen das ganz besondere
dort seien normal da hintergrund der
flatschacher berge für die fotografen
und wenn solche wolken szene wie heute
gibt gibt es auch mehr her als wenn wir
das über irgendwo am meer macht ja das
gelände sowieso eine ganz
außerordentliche geschichte
normalerweise wenn wir unterwegs sind
auf große herrschers ist dass er im
flachen land oder in der nähe von von
einem strand oder wo man etwas mehr
fliegt uns solche dinge aber gerade mit
sich gelände herausforderungen bedeutet
diese berge herum sein und so das ist
uns auch für unsere piloten
dies ist ja auch wissen von österreich
und erfordern vor österreich trotzdem
immer große herausforderungen und ich
bin überzeugt davon dass piloten die
aussie spanien oder wo auch herkommen
oder wie auch immer das ist ganz
besondere geschichte ist weil wie gesagt
nicht gewohnt seien in diesem
herausfordernden gelände zu fliegen okay
das heißt auf der sicherheit ist ganz
besonderer wert zulegen wie kam es im
sicherheits vergleich sehen sein
also mit allen diesen bereichen von der
von der sicherheit von der grube
betreuung von den abläufen her von der
klarheit der vorgangsweise sammelte auch
sicher in europa an erster position zu
sehen und wie vorher sagt ob es ist sehr
sehr
überraschend oder nicht überraschend
sondern sehr sehr erfreulich dass wir da
so einen großen standardbrief und
gegenüber auch anderen großen armeen und
luft hoffen ich glaube jetzt losgehen
was wenn man hat deswegen ja am start
sind zwei flugzeuge der flying bulls das
eine ist die p 38 lightning
das ist die silberne maschine gut
erkennbar da unterschiede und die zweite
maschine ist die f4 ucar sehr die blaue
maschine doch geflogen wird die
lightning von unserem chefpiloten der
fläche flieger raimund rittmann und in
der
kurse ist der skandal der pilot eines
geländers nur wegen zudem kommt ein
bisschen spezieller jedenfalls dann
diese zwei flugzeuge
fast baugleich von der zeit her die
diebe 38 lightning ist bei 1944
und die kurse 1945 und ein vorher der
vergleich mit eur freiheitsberaubung
alles mit 27 computer und frei bayerns
abgedeckt ist das ist dass da was hängen
ist handarbeit aber richtige handarbeit
und
natürlich auch unsere piloten
dementsprechend trainiert darauf um
solche geräte bewegen zu können
ja ich glaube jetzt losgehen im staat
unsere zwei maschinen macht auch vor so
genanntes formation the cove das heißt
sie fliegen zusammen gleich aus wenn
dann hinter uns vorbeikommen so werde
der planung kommen dann wiederum von der
ostseite dass diese gliedern herein die
b 38 lightning ist ein flugzeug im
zweiten weltkrieg ein jagdflugzeug des
zweiten weltkriegs gewesen wo alles auf
geschwindigkeit ausgelegt wurde die
amerikaner also diese maschine so
entwickelt um wirklich hohe
geschwindigkeiten damit zu erzeugen wenn
man bedenkt wenn man eine zweimotorige
oder viermotorige propellermaschine
sieht drehen sich die propeller in
dieselbe richtung normalerweise daraus
ergibt sich divis drehmoment und auch
ein gewisser luftwirbel um die maschine
um die wiederum energie verbraucht und
somit auf die geschwindigkeit geht bei
der lightning ist es so dass ich die
zwei propeller gegen gleich drehen und
durch dieses gegen gleich mit dieser
tour perfekt aufgehoben auch die
vorbildung ist eine andere und die
maschine herum und somit kann man sehr
sehr grosser geschwindigkeit fliegen die
lightning als propeller flugzeug fliegt
über 800 km h schnell also das ist sehr
sehr beeindruckend
in der damaligen zeit eigentlich wo die
düsenflugzeuge noch nicht so verbreitet
worden sei was den kriegsschauplätzen in
glaube es ist ja eher für den
asiatischen kriegsschauplatz für den
europäischen entwickelt worden und ich
uns in der masse ist im asiatischen
luftraum geflogen aber auch natürlich
auch in europa die zeit hat auch diese
ist diese technik überholt natürlich ist
es wenn man
diese technik verwendet man braucht zwei
verschiedene problem aber braucht zwei
verschiedene motoren und karim noch
steckt das ist so dass wir wenn wir bei
der tc 6 oder aber bei der b25 ein
propeller problem haben dann nehmen wir
einen ein aus dem lager heraus bei der
b38 ist die frage welchen braucht sie
hier den linken oder der rechten sowie
es ist eben nach schiebung und die
bereithaltung von nachschub material
sehr sehr schwierig aber es war dann die
zeit wo die strahltriebwerke aufgekommen
sind somit hat sich diese technik dann
überhaupt müsste haupt zur möglichkeit
irgendwo in ein ersatzteillager auf dem
weltmarkt zu greifen bei ihren
flugzeugen oder ist es so dass es doch
alles hängt von der hand gefertigt und
machen gebaut werden es gibt sehr sehr
viele ersatzteile nur weltweit das ist
natürlich um spannend das heißt auch
unser store oder unsere nachschub leute
im lager die haben ihre kontakte in
amerika da drüben da gibt es genug
flugzeug friedhof die solche maschinen
herum ständen und buden und da wird dann
einfach eingekauft es ist natürlich
immer ein bisserl problem wenn man das
aufs tor kaufte es ist es trotzdem ganz
60 70 jahre alt vielleicht sogar
verboten trotzdem 60 70 jahre alt wie
oft das rundbild freuen das heißt man
muss trotzdem dementsprechend genau
prüfen bevor was man einbaut und
verwendet und ausdruck kommt bei dieser
fliegerei aber flieger als allgemein so
von den kosten her das liegt 60 jahre
auf lagern und dann braucht sein dann
kann man sich vorstellen das ist auch
der preis dementsprechend ist
wir wollen der herzog dass die piloten
sich kurz
[Gelächter]
[Applaus]
jetzt scheint einiges koordinatoren zu
sehen ja wir haben mit gehört dass es
bei den logischerweise diesen älteren
modellen oder flugzeugen auch mal zu
problemen kommen kann das hier ist
nichts gravierendes aber wie wir volk
sagte sicherheit geht vor das heißt es
wird die situation dieses er hat ein
kleines problem in der leitung drinnen
er wird mit der leitung oder kurs er
hier in den überflug noch machen aber
dann wird die lightnings sofort zurück
nach salzburg gehen mit diesem kleinen
technischen problem also kein problem
zum nach hause fliegen aber nicht mehr
gewährleisteten sich als display zu
fliegen und somit wird dann das display
quasi alleine absolvieren bei diesen
betagten verteilers
leider ist es oft so
ja da benutzer lightning hat mir gerade
mitgeteilt was ein problem ist er hat
beim einziehen des fahrwerkes ist der
vordere fahrwerksklappen offen geblieben
also kein problem für ihn eigentlich
zurück zu fliegen das ist keine
großartige sache aber es ist nicht mehr
hundertprozentig tausendprozentig sicher
dass im display zu fliegen mit offener
fahrwerksklappen und darum fliegt er
vorsichtshalber nach hause und die quasi
auch kommt rein für eine vorführung
europa ein flugzeug das über 60 jahre
ist verstehe ich das bei mir das knie
will
ich hatte den verbraucher aus
die kann man auch immer als ich
fahrschule hatte mit einem
buch
damals beim bundesheer das auto gelände
ab da hat 26 liter braucht bei 120 ps
und 16 ja also meister pro kilometer
damit kommen so hat ist der rechten
seite kommt die kurse ein
df vor und kurse war auch im zweiten
weltkrieg in der masse auf
flugzeugträger gestützt man kann das ja
die flügel hochklappen bei der maschine
um einen play-off-platz
management zu haben
wie gesagt war 1945 hat eine nacht zehn
zylinder doppelreihen sternmotor drinnen
und
bist du vor dass anspruch ist beim sprit
okay das ist natürlich ein gewisser
verbrauch ist dann gegeben wenn man so
eine mutter hat mit circa 2000 100 ps
bei dem stern natur ist auch interessant
ist eines der module auf den sauber und
wenn dann eine ungerade zylinder und
somit hat in einer reihe neuen zylinder
und dieses zweiten reihe hinter den
nächsten neun zylinder
und da bis zum vergleich der hubraum von
diesem motor mit den 18 zylinder der
motor ist 46 liter hubraum das ungefähr
30 pkw wenn man ein pkw mazda auf dem
friedhof errechnet also 46 liter hubraum
hat 790 liter motoröl drinnen und sehr
sehr sehr kraftvolle maschine durch eine
große tank
fasst ein volumen von 600 liter und
damit kommentierte zwei stunden in der
luft bleiben
der pilot der maschine ist der skandal
ein norweger der seit drei jahren jetzt
beim diensten der flying bulls ist der
skandal ist ein sehr bekannter
pilotinnen flugreisen er war sehr sehr
lange bei der norwegischen air force war
dort der einführungs pilot und der
testpilot der 9 11 35 also der lightning
2 wo sie überall auf der welt herum geht
ist dann auch
war danach jahrelange
jahrelang testpilot bei eurofighter
fliegt dennoch einzig existierten
starfighter der nur wegen steht und
fliegt alle
so genannte warbirds die bei uns gesehen
aber auch viele andere mehr er hat also
über 120 flugzeugtypen in seinem buch
drin stehen
unglaublich
da oder mit einer doppel fürstentum
auch viele
auch die maschine erreicht die
geschwindigkeit von knapp 700 km h
und das ist jetzt sein wird sein letzter
überflug seien da kommt ja es geht mit
der kurs herein und wird sich dann hier
auf der linken seite abstellen maschine
steht dafür bar infos zur verfügung geht
dann zurück nach salzburg
herzlichen dank erst wenn danke für die
aufmerksamkeit